[Music]
everywhere you look in the world people
are adulterous even where you can get
your head chopped off or stoned that
means that it probably has some
biological predisposition there's all
kinds of cultural reasons that people
are adulterous if you ask a person why
they are daughters they may say well I
get lonely when my partner's out of town
I want to solve a sex problem I'd like
to have more sex I'd like to get caught
and patch up my marriage I'd like to get
caught and end my marriage I'd like to
supplement my marriage but scientists
are beginning to find out some
biological predispositions a
predisposition doesn't mean that you're
necessarily going to be adulterous I
mean you can have a predisposition to
alcoholism and give up drinking and
there's some things about the brain that
seem to predispose some people to
adultery one of them is a set of genes
or a gene we're not quite sure which in
the vasopressin system and there was a
wonderful study that out of Sweden they
studied a gene in the vasopressin among
552 men some men had no copies of the
gene some had one copy of the gene and
some had two copies of the gene and the
more copies of this gene you had the
less stable your primary relationship
was they were not studying adultery but
they were studying the stability of a
partnership which can certainly lead to
adultery if it's in stable there's also
some genes in the immune system that
seemed to play a role in adultery we
tend to be drawn to people who have a
different set of genes in this part of
the immune system and in fact when the
data show that when you are with a
partner who is very similar to you in
this part of the immune system women
particularly are more likely to be in
daughters and more likely to be
adulterous when they're ovulating when
they're more likely to get pregnant
I think we've evolved these three
distinctly different brain systems from
mating and reproduction sex drive
feelings of intense romantic love and
feelings of deep attachment they're
often connected to each other you can
fall in love with somebody it drives up
the dopamine system triggers the
testosterone system and all of a sudden
that the sexiest person in the whole
world
but they're not always well connected
you can lie in bed at night
and feel deep attachment for one person
and then swing wildly into feelings of
intense romantic love for somebody else
and then swing wildly into feeling the
sex drive for somebody who you've barely
ever met which made me wonder whether
millions of years ago there was
something adaptive about having a
partnership with one person and raising
your babies and having extra
relationships with other people and it's
actually relatively easy to explain
let's dial back a million years you got
a man who has got a wife a partnership
and two children and he occasionally
goes over the hill and and sleeps with
another woman and has two children extra
children with her he's doubled the
amount of DNA he has spread into the
next generation those children will live
and pass on whatever it is in him some
of the genetics some of the brain
circuitry to be predisposed to adultery
but why would a woman be adulterous a
lot of people think that they're not as
adulterous but every time there's a man
sleeping around he's generally sleeping
around with a woman so you got to
explain women to what would a woman have
gotten if she's had a partner a million
years ago and two children she slips
over the hill and has sex with another
man what she'll get extra goods and
resources extra meat extra protection if
her husband gets injured and dies and
one of these extra lovers might come in
and help her with her children even
think some of those children are he is
it's an insurance policy and she may
even have an extra child and create more
genetic variety in her lineage so bottom
line is for millions of years there were
some reproductive payoffs not only to
forming a pair bond but also to adultery
leaving each one of us with a tremendous
drive to fall in love and pair up but
also some susceptibility to cheating on
the side
you
[Music]